AND FINALLY,
WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT DONALD STERLING
IS A DISGUSTING BIGOT,
AND HE GOT WHAT HE DESERVED.
GO AHEAD.
LET YOUR VOICES BE HEARD!
LET YOUR VOICES BE HEARD.
BUT...
LET'S NOT TURN
A COMPLETE BLIND EYE
TO THE FACT THAT
THERE'S ANOTHER HORRIBLE PERSON
IN THIS SITUATION:
HIS 30-SOMETHING-YEAR-OLD
GOLD-DIGGING MISTRESS.
SHE'S GETTING OFF PRETTY EASY
IF YOU ASK ME.
YOU KNOW WHO DOESN'T BANG
A MARRIED 80-YEAR-OLD RACIST
FOR FOUR YEARS?
A GOOD PERSON.
IT'S GETTING TO WHERE
YOU CAN'T TRUST A LADY ANYMORE.
WHY IS EVERYONE
ALWAYS SECRETLY RECORDING
THE PEOPLE THEY LOVE?
MY GIRLFRIEND CAN FEEL FREE
TO LEAK OUR PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS ANYTIME.
I'M AN OPEN BOOK.
THANK GOODNESS
SHE DIDN'T FILM THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SAYING ALL THAT
IN BLACKFACE.